elga me per una settimana ogni tanto
farò questa uscita cioè non me basta per
tutti i ragazzi sta settimana diventiamo
tamarri come a torino afghana quando io
ero piccolo ero ragazzino a torino c'era
non è stato tipo ciao come stai tutto
questo se adesso ancora proprio questo
pick di voce proprio orribile perché ci
mettono così tanto a caricare che carica
così lento cala più ne sono io mi date
delle armi per favore grazie a ben ten
in alto fa niente generosità perché mi
spara al rosso fa niente questa è la
prendo c'è ma con gli esplosivi faccia
sì però di morire ma perché era un muore
tra vivo realize andate bene e pensavo
peggio c'è il rosso che fermo si
suicidano c'è la paura attenzione ha
ucciso io adesso ci sono riuscito anche
il rosso madonna come gioco bene oggi ma
cosa è successo è relativo questo via
vai via vai lontano per favore anzi lo
veline io vicino perché sono madonna che
ciò mancato che è possibile che non son
riuscito uccidano di tutto questo si è
ucciso da solo è ancora vivo e che è
molto credibile
luca ragazzi la gara troppo quella lista
partita che abbiamo la per cambiarla
perché la mamma mia non ho mai visto
gente la gare così tanto uno schifo è
cambiato però bellissimo novità tra di
fila che dice ora che cabina partita
come minimo mi ammazzano prova di vanto
dietro l'albero nomi a nessuno foto con
la chiama incredibile
sono vivo ora vero poi non ci credo che
non ho vinto
non ci credo basta rimanere proprio
tanto così ma all'inizio fece male che
ho io questa mia non rompete le balle
premio alla fine quello che la presa e
morto intorno a posto la hepburn
oddio che qua devi andare esattamente
nel buco dove sta il rosso che ci metto
io
questo picchiandolo sono so se siamo
tutti morti qua c'è un serpente c'è un
serpente nel google ha vinto il blu non
si sa cosa sia successo ha vinto perché
voci aveva voglia di vincere
avrei dovuto vincere io tantissimo www
questa buona buono riqua riuscito a
cristo sono successe delle robe che non
ho capito ma ho vinto l'importante
questo ragazzi ricordate lo prendo io
grazie ai a e mori e mori io proprio
d'armi non lo so io quando un'arma in
mano e facebook quando non arrivano
muoio è peggio
cosa volete fare voi due guardandovi
negli occhi guardate negli occhi che
succede provincia il verde non ha fatto
niente sono stare fermo ok tutto kia ha
vinto il beh complimenti
il verde è stato incredibile prova usare
anche st tattica rimane fermo via se
funziona
ha mai sparato però cosa ciò io di
diverso dal verde siamo tutti fermi ce
lo può fare quello che vuole ma stavo
scherzando è un bluff
era un bluff vado anche dal rosso no è
sopravvissuto tipo dio grando in giorgio
che non muore mai pensare non riesco a
prendere quest'anno voglio che stiamo io
quella viola voglio quella di rocky è
fortissimo non esca prenderla voglio
eccola là come cosa ha vinto il blu
rosso e ancora vivo io volevo fare
vincere il rosso vincere era se l'ha
schiacciato il rosso era morto per
quello madonna che il disastro sono vivo
come sia possibile bellissimo ho vinto
ho fatto un casino bellissimo camorra è
il rosso è stato cliccato visto ai
serpenti guardano al nostro quanto sia
utile tenetevela voi quindi anche quello
ormai siamo io contro il blu ragazzi si
spara madonna qui c'è gente che ha
un'arma io no beato il verde aiuto
sono vivo no sono morto l'inter verbo ce
l'ha vinto il blu quindi adesso deciderà
se uscire si può far vincere perdere se
non vincerai perde di nuovo è una
questione di capire se suicidarsi o meno
spara madonna a hai rotto sempre tu con
le armi è rotto
poi rosso non c'è prima era morto prof
anche il bene adesso se il nostro che è
successo proprio lui e rosso e ad ogni
tanto torno di tanto se ne va fortuna è
fortissimo ma dove li che si sta
sparando vai contro di lui non andare
contro di me porca vacca quello rimane
sempre da solo col verde ma trai pistola
al contrario tanto di caduta un'altra
pistola in testa
ok va bene ragazzuoli allora fate vedere
che siete degli avversari degni che ogni
volta che gioco devo fare il deretano
nella maniera incredibile cosa sta
succedendo con lanciarazzi lì cosa sto
eletto a valence budan e pinocchio
arrivo ragazzi siete morti tutti
sappiatelo schiacciate tutti ancora vivo
sono carico a capirla bene aiuto
sparagli sparagli aia palas anatema
trovare volta sono deficiente sono un
pirla è vero tutto avevo vinto
praticamente passava a sfruttare bene la
mia posizione ovini
pirla proprio dai come ha fatto a
prendermi madonna ragazza c'è veramente
l'ansia bella tutto a posto è morite ma
basta
ma la gente non muore mai sono morto
sono vivo sono vivo sono fatto sono vivo
non capisco sono ma sono molto buono
buono buono bastard birthday noto le
balle cavalca aspetta che io sono
sparito non ho neanche più visto il mio
personaggio va bene fa niente se non
diamo pinocchio salvo l'abbiamo fatto
anche prima faceva bene devi togliere
togliti tutti i morti tutti i morti
rimasto io e il bird ovviamente allora
come fa vincesse per verde ma basta no
ragazzi con i quali diamoci questo uomo
incredibile pazzo penso che fa guarda
guarda ciò lanciarazzi madonna se non
vinco stavolta andiamo al bar o anche la
famiglia ce la faccio la gara oggi non
c'è vero la cina riesca a vincere ma
l'armani a dichiararmi valeva niente
gialle qua dobbiamo andare a rompere
balle siamo tranquilli
stai fermo io dovrei dovrei dare di
sopra ci sono due legali quindi mi
avvantaggia non erano ideali qua eh no
ragazzi c'è qualcosa che non va in
stampa c'è e non vinco mai non sto
vincendo mai anche quando vinco non
vinco ma come il verde era sotto era
sotto il verde io sono rimasto
incastrato sono incastrato aiuto ho
vinto io per ora volta ho vinto io ma
oggi proprio è difficile non so come mai
c'è proposto tronto la difficoltà perché
spari a me è frutto pezzente l'altro di
st quello che salta in bocca e spari a
me va file wav aiff cos'è sta roba
l'aiuto di sotto dopo il giro ci arrivo
io
sai io lo vedo la gente non vedo io ho
preso un fucile a pompa non vedo niente
quello cioè cosa dei serpenti di sparo e
non voglio sarei morto sei volte sei
volte sarei morto sei volte maori gli ho
sparato con due fucili a pompa in porta
non è morto ma dai
a una pistola ci vado io allora io sono
morto
il che è incredibile perché io ho
sparato con un fucile a pompa 80 colpi
di pistola l'ho picchiato e sono molto
io quindi impossibile in più è risolto
il blu guarda non muore il verde non
muore non muore lì o se io capisco dati
si fanno danno stavolta oggi no guarda
guarda guarda guarda guarda oggi non
muore la gente
ma cosa sparare non vuole non vogliono
cosa devo fare bene così se vuoi che
faccia ha sparato tanta volte cosa vuoi
colpo ma cosa ci ammazza se non si
abbassano da soli non muoiono oggi non
so cosa devo fare ma con le teche che
gay
no no arrivo no ha vinto il giallo che
non ha fatto una sega ok e chico ha
guardato muoio io se ci parliamo a
cazzotti non so perché iper cazzotti
valgono di più dei miei vedi nei capi
non abbiamo una pistola io ti sparo in
bocca ad ogni spara in bocca muoio io tu
sei a posto perché i miei proiettili non
valgono una sedia proprio i missili sono
proiettili finti di gomma i miei il
nostro come mai se ci fate caso i due
ore che spa guarda guarda io sarei morto
tanta volte meno male che s'è suicidato
chi è che c'è la corona cioè io mi ci
metto sotto
ho fatto non ci guarda guarda e mortola
sono porto io gli ho sparato io sono
morto io come ma oggi cosa succede
ma perché come mai oggi non riesco a
fare niente cioè io sparo l'agente muoio
io cioè incredibile imbarazzante posso
smettere a ritrovarmi di serpenti che
cosa me ne faccio ho dato molto
tranquillo quindi vieni pure è andato
sui 7 è un babbo ria che sto vincendo
solo se si ammazzano da soli sto
vincendo che guarda guarda guarda quanti
colpi se preso ego e muoio io muoio
[Musica]